It's Black History Month.
It's the one month of the year
where we all get together
and talk about race.
And how we pretty much fixed it.
But the social justice warriors
will woke-splain to you
that this month is a time for me
to learn something.
Listen and take a backseat.
It's not gonna happen.
I'm not taking a backseat.
I have to sit up front because I
get motion sickness.
Moving forward makes me puke.
It's a very common ailment for
people like me,
so riding shotgun with me is
Kobi Libii.
Welcome, Kobi.
(cheering and applause)
Thank you, Jordan.
I'm here to bring attention
to an important cause out there,
BLM.
Wait, are... are you talking
about Black Lives Matter?
Oh, God no, I'm not some
militant radical.
I'm talking about BLM:
Black lives? Manners.
Because, as we all know,
there is an epidemic
of impoliteness in
the black community.
And it could easily turn into a
case of systemic rudeness.
The Black, the Black Lives
Manners movement
has its roots in the Jim Crow
era, where,
if you were impolite
to white people
you were scolded... with murder.
And to make sure I'm up on the
good etiquette, I check-in
with television's home for
Black History Month, Fox News.
These guys just don't
see race.... until they do,
and then immediately become an
authority on it.
I should know, I went to
Fox News finishing school.
So, like many black men in
America, I'm virtually finished.
Isn't the mascot over there the
"fighting status quos"?
Yes, indeed.
And all across Fox News, they're
taking advantage of this month
to really listen...
to themselves telling
black people how to act.
After the State of the Union,
Geraldo had some really
helpful advice
for the congressional
black caucus.
Everybody's parents teach them
manners.
Manners are very simple.
How can you not cheer
if you're a member of the
congressional black caucus
for historic low black and
Latino unemployment?
-I mean.
-TV REPORTER: Of course.
That's an applause line.
I-I don't care who says it.
Sure, he looks like
if Willy Wonka ran
a tanning salon,
but he makes a great point.
If it's an applause line,
you applaud.
So what if Donald Trump
mildly supported
some tiki torch
white nationalists.
He still said one nice thing
in his speech.
Say Jack the Ripper gave
a "state of the serial killer"
address, saying,
"sex worker wages
are on the rise."
The women he left alive owe him
a standing ovation.
That's just good manners.
-Yes, yes, yes, yes.
-Right?
It is, it's all about manners.
But it doesn't stop there.
Let's jump over
to Laura Ingraham,
Fox News' rich aunt
at the picnic.
She saw that
Congresswoman Maxine Waters
gave a response
to Trump's speech,
and she just knew that she had
to offer a helping hand.
Give us the angle, Ingraham.
BET featured a response
to the State of the Union
-a day after the
State of the Union. -Yeah.
Whenever he appears on TV,
there should be a disclaimer
that says,
"This may not be acceptable
for children."
First of all,
was Maxine Waters--
did-did a child make
the backdrop for that set?
-What was that?
-(laughing)
Nothing says you're seriously
engaging with someone's ideas
like criticizing
their camera backdrop.
Yes, exactly.
And Laura is an expert on
backdrops.
Her show really captured
the feeling
of living inside a game of
off-brand Tetris.
See Maxine's crime is
she's no fun.
Black manners dictate that if
you want to participate
in the public discourse,
you need to be either fun,
or grateful, and, ideally, both.
Like pre-Scientology Will Smith.
Exactly, Jordan.
But if black people don't speak
in a humble, accessible way,
the rest of America
won't hear them.
Just listen to Greg Gutfeld.
If you look up "ally"
in the Urban Dictionary,
you'll find Greg.
He's been laser-focused
on the issue
of NFL players kneeling
during the national anthem.
Now, everyone knows that started
as a protest
against police brutality,
but Greg does a great job
of also not knowing it.
The kneeling stuff
was poorly articulated.
Nobody really knew
what it meant.
It had-it had...
People had to keep repeating it
over and over again,
and it became
a question of patriotism,
not a question of brutality.
Yes, they had to say it
so many times,
as if no one cared to listen.
And because players
weren't being articulate,
the good people at Fox News
had to grab the bullhorn
and tell protesters
what they're really protesting.
(reading):
Kaepernick disrespects
the national anthem.
Disrespect for the flag.
Disrespecting our anthem.
Disrespect our troops.
If you listen close,
you can hear these commentators
beating us over the head
with the idea of disrespect.
Where are the manners,
protesters?
That's systemic rudeness.
Yes, these protests
are just so disruptive
when all I'm trying to do
is have a good time
not considering
what they're about.
And you should be able
to enjoy yourself.
The Black Lives Matter movement
is all about
keeping black people alive,
while the Black Lives? Manners!
movement is all about
keeping white people
comfortable.
Because if you study
American history,
you'll notice that white comfort
has always been more important
than black lives.
And Fox News knows that.
So let's not rock the boat,
even if the boat
is carrying slaves
on a horrifying journey
to America.
-Well, I got...
-(cheering and applause)
Kobi, I... I will say...
I certainly don't feel
white comfortable right now.
Oh, don't worry, Jordan.
Black History Month
is practically over already.
-February is basically a week.
-(laughs)
So, you-you think we can have
this whole race thing
-wrapped up by March?
-Oh, yes.
Oh, and it's called
White March, Jordan.
The month we focus on
all the great white marches
that will no doubt be happening
-in response
to Black History Month.